It's been a great show.
I had a playdate with my BFFs,
Mike got murky
with some ethicists
and I showed Ana Marie Cox
why she should never have me
on her podcast.
("Wah-wah" gibberish)
I know. I know, general.
I'm getting to it.
Mooch?
Do I really have to go?
(audience groaning)
Now that our love is so new?
I'm sorry,
but Kelly says you got to.
For real this time.
At least now can I go see
my wife and newborn son.
(laughter)
No, I'm not gonna to do that.
But there is one more thing
before I go.
There's an old
Italian expression.
You know what it is.
I know, baby.
(cheering and applause)
Oh, my God.
("Wah-wah" gibberish)
-Take him away, general.
-I love you.
-I love you, Mr. President.
-Take him away.
I love you. I love you.
-I love you.
-I freaking love you.
-I love you so much.
-(sobs)
I'll miss you, Mr. President.
I'll miss you, Christian man.
I'll miss you most of all.
Look, he's trying to do it.
I told you.
He's really trying to do it.
He's trying
to suck his own (bleep).
You'll never make it,
you fat bastard.
(grunts)
There we go.
-Back to complete chaos.
-Ah, ew.
Just the way I like it.